hey guys I'm Sophia Carson I'm Sydney
Park I'm Julie brown I'm Janel Parrish
and I'm Sasha Pieterse ax and we are
here at BuzzFeed and we're super pumped
because we're about to take the which
Pretty Little Liars a perfectionist cast
member are you quiz first question how
would your BFFs describe you
ambitious fierce passionate motivated
optimistic sincere I'm going to say yeah
I think so yeah
passionately my answer is fierce
I chose passion ever since choose a
vacation spot
Dublin Santorini Tokyo Paris Barcelona
or Maui well I got married in Ireland
and spent most of the week in Dublin or
my favorite places so and definitely
cheese and I got married in Hawaii and
it's one of our favorite places so I'm
gonna choose my way so cool I loved that
way too
I'm gonna go with Paris because I was
just there for a strike and want to go
back I'm having withdrawals I would say
Paris cuz I've never been and I took the
language for three years in school and I
want to like it yeah thank you very much
stuff but I think Maui is my choice
myself Dublin that is so you choose a
superpower tell and tell the hotel ff8
talapia telepathy superhuman strength
invisibility travel I'm no celebrity
I think Kealing but wait no time travel
that was you might and going back to
Lake Woodstock wait boy it's not for you
of course like the 1950s like Audrey
Hepburn Grace Kelly era it'll be my
choice invisibility would be really good
too I would love to be a fly on the wall
I'm going with invisibility cuz there
are times where I just like like chill I
got a radar I'm gonna go with healing
you're such that was actually a really
really suck it's not true cuz you can go
back in time and save people this is
true mm-hmm this is true which college
class would you want to take this is
good because I didn't good all I know
which one we're choosing immediately
back on introduction to wine
Janell Disney 101 the art of taking a
selfie how to create a viral meme the
art of binge watching arts and crafts
101 I think they are taking a selfie I
absolutely my introduction to why boom
choose a late-night snack to eat while
studying granola bar popcorn peanut
butter and jelly sandwich Pizza chips
and guac candy
I love oh that's all I can make so I'm
gonna go with popcorn okay a PB&J for
sure chips in Guatemala are very similar
on that you're at my soul sister she was
something important from the original
pretty little liars red truck Alison's
yellow shirt the dollhouse Radley
sanitarium Rosewood high school or a is
lair mmm the dollhouse I'm gonna go with
feet palaces yellow shirt
oh it only is an iconic I'm gonna pick
Alison's yellow shirt not because I
liked that shirt just because it was so
iconic well it was so important
throughout the show it was like always
went back to that night and I'm gonna
choose the red trench coat is it goes
off so important in a life finally chose
at teen TV series our gossip is wise
pretty liars on on this one tree hill
Gossip Girl
do see Teen Wolf Boy Meets World and
Gilmore Girls I don't know the girl got
a roll back sweet Kelly Reilly revered
as a queen does it girl I think Boy
Meets World
yeah I'm amazed I got home I got Caitlin
Lewis you guys got your characters yeah
this I got we take so I just for took
and I got Mona which I will accept I
love Mona but I don't
how do I get any of all it's a trick to
just be yourself
I try I'm doing this again retake clear
no I got it strong personalities we get
everybody on the show except yourself we
had so much fun so much fun you have
take the quiz you really really have to
take this quiz and tweet us your answers
please tune in to pretty little liars a
perfectionist on what is this I'm free
from 8 o'clock p.m. so ever get David
please hit me up
[Music]